les canadiens paie cher très cher leurs
médicaments 25% de plus en moyenne pour
les mêmes produits que dans les autres
pays développés
après trois ans de consultations ottawa
veut corriger la situation avec
effectivement sauver 13 oublie arriver
le conseil d'examen du prix des
médicaments brevetés cessera de comparer
les prix canadiens aux prises américains
les plus élevés au monde pour plutôt se
baser sur les coûts en australie japon
des pays où réalité plus proche de celle
du canada gouvernement sert aussi la vis
aux compagnies pharmaceutiques et les
forcera à dévoiler le prix réel des
médicaments sur le marché bien plus bas
que les prix officiels souvent gonflés
confronté à ces changements
l'industrie montent aux barricades et
prédit des effets néfastes des menaces
que rejette cet expert de l'industrie
pharmaceutique au pays et aucun lien
entre le niveau des prix et le niveau de
dépenses en recherche et développement
je devais en ce moment on situe derrière
la pologne ou la croatie en termes
d'aidé de l'investissement par rapport
au ventre
les canadiens devront toutefois attendre
avant de voir le prix de leurs
médicaments baisser ces changements
n'entreront en vigueur que dans un an
en toute fin de mandat la ministre se
défend d'avoir trop attendu
nous avons pris les traits de consulter
avec l'opposition néo démocrates
accusent des libéraux d'électoralisme on
va finalement faire ce qu'on avait dit
qu'on allait faire l'an 2010 à qui on
annonce hall mois avant les élections
soient déclenchées les libéraux
présentent cette réduction des prix
comme la première étape vers la création
le régime national d'assurance
médicaments pas de doute tout est
maintenant en place pour que la question
se retrouve au coeur de la prochaine
campagne électorale
ici mathieu gaye i radio canada ottawa